la parole est maintenant à madame
colette mélot pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur jean marc ayrault ministre des
affaires étrangères et du développement
international
une onde de choc a traversé l'europe le
24 juin le break site a donné lieu à des
démissions royaume uni et à des
réactions dans les 27 autres pays de
l'union européenne après le conseil
européen
la situation reste confuse pourtant
cette crise agit comme un révélateur et
doit permettre en recentrage des
priorités pour l'union européenne une
refondation de l'europe s'impose
l'objectif de paix qui sait que
s'étaient fixés les pères fondateurs a
été atteint le niveau de vie des
européens s'est élevé aujourd'hui
d'autres défis sont devant nous les
attentes de nos concitoyens concerne la
sécurité et la maîtrise des frontières
la croissance et l'emploi en particulier
pour la jeunesse or depuis que 17
millions 400 mille britanniques ont voté
pour une sortie de l'union européenne
nous avons le sentiment que le président
hollande est aussi silencieux que
démunis et la commission ne semble pas
vraiment tirer les leçons de cet
événement inédit
j'en veux pour preuve l'ouverture d'un
nouveau chapitre pour l'adhésion de la
turquie
monsieur le ministre ma question est la
suivante
saurez vous contribuez à faire du break
site l'électrochoc que les français
attendent
la parole est à monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères du développement
international jean marc ayrault
il faut il faut madame monsieur le
président merci madame la sénatrice il
faut mener de front les deux questions
des deux questions c'est à dire à la
fois gérer la sortie de la
grande-bretagne
comme je viens de le rappeler une autre
votre collègue le sénateur richard yung
et en même temps relancé le projet
européen qui en a besoin mais pour ça il
faut éviter d'utiliser les arguments qui
cherche uniquement à faire peur
l'adhésion de la turquie n'est pas
l'ordre du jour demain matin vous le
savez fort bien d'ailleurs les chapitres
qui ont été ouverts non mais les
chapitres qui ont été ouverts vous venez
de le rappeler depuis 2012 trois
chapitres sous la législature précédente
c'est à dire sur le président sarkozy
aux chapitres cela qui en a eu plus donc
s'il vous plaît n'utilisez pas cet
argument mais en même temps là vous avez
raison c'est qu'il faut que l'europe
reprennent redonne tout son sens au
projet des pères fondateurs il faut
qu'elles reviennent aux sources
et là il ya un travail considérable à
faire je partage votre ambition et c'est
là qu'il faut mettre sur la table une
série de propositions
j'aime ans même avec mon homologue frank
walter steinmeier ministre affaires
étrangères de république fédérale
d'allemagne fait des propositions qui
portent à la fois sur le thème de la
sécurité sécurité intérieure sécurité en
dehors de nos frontières
la nouveau défi stratégique comment
aborder aussi la question migratoire
dans la clarté la solidarité en
distinguant les réfugiés des millésimes
des migrants économiques comment
organiser notre relation entre l'europe
et l'afrique
et puis également la question de
l'avenir des investissements d'avenir la
croissance et l'emploi et puis enfin
l'approfondissement de la zone euro qui
est nécessaire et puis tout en
travaillant sur la question d'un
meilleur fonctionnement de toutes les
institutions européennes sans
systématiquement dire c'est la faute à
la commission parce que ça c'est un peu
une facilité et puis en même temps de
prendre à bras le corps la question de
jeunesse
nous avons été capables de faire erasmus
maintenant il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin
donner des signes concrets pour que
l'europe retrouve son élan retrouve sa
force c'est notre responsabilité c'est
pour ça que le conseil européen a décidé
d'un conseil extraordinaire qui aura
lieu le 16 septembre à bratislava
d'ici là rassurez-vous la france
continuera d'apporter ses propres
propositions pour les mettre en débat et
faire à nouveau avancer l'europe
madame mélo monsieur le ministre les
français attendent une réponse politique
et veulent que nous sortions de la
logique technocratique l'absence d'
influence du gouvernement dans la
relation franco allemande
l'absence de leadership du président
hollande sur la scène européenne et le
manque d'autorité il faut bien le dire
de monsieur juncker sont très
préoccupants
si nous n'y prenons garde tout
continuera comme avant
et c'est ce que les baux conclus refuse
merci